there is new evidence every day of
progress in ukraine's fight against
russia the fireball in this video along
ukraine's southeast coast appears to be
from a direct hit on a russian supply
ship farther north near kiev ukrainians
are moving to retake a town that was
claimed by the russians holly williams
is in the southwest of kiev in the city
of venezia ali good morning
good morning ukrainian authorities
claimed yesterday that russia has
forcibly moved more than four hundred
000 of this country's people into russia
now we cannot independently verify that
assertion to put it in perspective
though that is roughly the population of
the entire metro area of savannah
georgia but here inside ukraine the
fight continues
ukrainian forces say they're close to
recapturing urpin
around 14 miles north of kiev
the russian assault has torn this place
to shreds a thriving town reduced to a
wasteland with very few residents left
when most fled earlier this month there
were horrifying scenes as russian forces
opened fire on civilians
but the mood of the ukrainian soldiers
now as they claw back control of
european seems to be upbeat everybody
fear for their lives
but most important it's a freedom
freedom of our nation and future of our
nation the ukrainian fight back is being
fueled by tens of thousands of ordinary
citizens young and old who are signing
up to fight
at this military base we found new
recruits coming to grips with an
anti-aircraft weapon getting schooled on
this heavy machine gun and learning to
fire mortars officers here told us
they'll only get around one week's basic
training before heading to the front
line
to ukraine these volunteers shout
followed by an insult to vladimir putin
which we can't repeat on television in
the armory they told us they're
receiving weapons from nato countries
the officer in charge wouldn't show his
face for security reasons they're
stocked with rpg rockets ak-47s and
bigger guns this sniper rifle made in
tennessee arrived with directions in
english you'll figure it out
but they told us they need more as well
as vehicles to move their soldiers to
the front if we don't stop
putting in ukraine he will go more
lieutenant miroslav hai was a filmmaker
and reservist before russia invaded his
country russian for example can use
nuclear weapon but it's don't stop
ukrainians even if vladimir putin
decides to use a nuclear weapon you
won't stop fighting don't stop fighting
we've heard a lot of anger from
ukrainians a lot of emotion that their
country is under assault but something
that we have not heard any ukrainian do
is complain
not once they're simply getting on with
the job of defending their homeland
and it's been inspiring for the entire
world holly we also are learning more
about that ukrainian attack on a russian
ship at a port in southeastern ukraine
what more can you tell us about it this
morning
well vlad this looks like a major
victory for the ukrainian military
amateur video shows what we understand
is or or was a russian naval supply ship
on fire in fact it looks like a giant
fireball this is in the port of
berdyansk video also seems to show other
russian ships fleeing the scene another
one also looks very badly damaged now we
don't know how the ukrainians did this
as you know they are massively outgunned
but this will certainly lift the spirits
of people here in ukraine vlad massively
outgunned but inspiring nonetheless
holly williams in western ukraine thank
you very much